we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two David P I am called
out by Troy York using one of his many
pseudonyms for not wearing a mask take a
listen to this hold on a second I guess
I hit the wrong button here we go
hey Pac Man woody Underwood from
Indianapolis Indiana
sureiy I've listening to your video
about my not wearing a mask and what's
really funny is that in your video you
are not wearing a mask so how often you
wear a mask and why aren't you wearing
one for your stupid podcast and no one
really watches except maybe box right
and your your game friends in Boston who
brutally homophobic I think that you
ought to take a couple masks put some
mayonnaise on it or in some butter yeah
this guy calls into the show eight to
ten times a week by the way so listen
I'm wearing a mask when I go into any
grocery store or post office or whatever
I don't wear one on the show because I'm
at home I'm just sitting in my house so
it would be really weird to wear a mask
we have updates on the bonus show about
Kim jong-un we will talk about a women's
soccer lawsuit losing an attempt at
equal pay and we will also talk about a
court weighing in as to whether mass
gathering bans should apply to churches
I believe that they should all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
get instant access by becoming a member
at join pakman.com or a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show